get ready for relationship shake ups and
surprising strip downs in this week
Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes I'm your
particular host lana Galera and I'm
still processing Riverdale's insane
antics in episode 208 chapter 21 house
of the devil that's why my hair so big
today you guys secrets now we have so
many mind-blowing romance revelations to
discuss and I'm seriously fired up right
now so my hisses and kisses are going to
be in full force plus I've got some
special guest commentary from tawny
topaz herself Vanessa Morgan so get
excited but first let's kick it all off
for the top headlines of the week in
this blue and gold breakdown first up
we've got some Reaper revelations now
remember that creepy truck driver from
last week's episode who told Jughead
about the Reaper who murdered a family
in Riverdale well it turns out it was in
the exact same house that the black hood
sent Betty to an episode 204 okay go
back there what yeah now this week bug
head took a break from their detective
duties and past the trench coats and
bobby pins over to Veronica and Archie
so you want us to be you guys
now the duo discovered that the Reaper
only killed four out of five family
members and the mi a little boy grew up
to be creepy janitor Svendsen yeah he
said that Riverdale townies killed the
Reaper but it's unclear if that's the
truth or how this whole thing is
connected to the black hood next it's
time to celebrate
cuz f P Jones is officially out of jail
and he's hoping to slither away from the
serpents for good but did you really
think that the king could leave his
throne that easily uh uh now in order to
protect Jughead from penny Peabody's
wrath FP kept his crown and possibly
found a new Queen to rule by his side
mom
need I remind you you were a serpent
side know who else thinks the F P and
Alice totally dated when they were teens
now I was sensing it's an angry love
between those two serpents how would
never come well then leave them at home
but tell me if you think I'm crazy
in the comments below now while we're on
this subject let's shine the spotlight
on all the couples chaos in this week's
seven seconds in heaven oh my goodness
it was a week jam-packed with some rough
waters for our favorite ships but things
started off hot and heavy for barchi
with a montage of all of the different
places they've been hooking up it's like
they were trying to win a sexcapade
scavenger hunt let their bedroom
rendevouz quickly stopped as soon as r2
dropped those three little words swooned
right wrong
rani could not bring herself to say the
phrase back to her redheaded boo and she
quickly realized that her I love you
allergies stemmed from the fact that
she's never heard her parents say it now
in the end Rani decided that she's not
ready to say the l-bomb and it looks
like Riverdale's most heated couple is
about to fizzle out I'm sorry
now over in Buckhead news things seem to
be back on track for the on-again
off-again duo
and Betty was even looking for a way to
join the serpent's as a way stay closer
to juggy you want to be a serpent
unfortunately Betty's surprising and
slithering striptease more on that in a
moment
rub Jughead the wrong way and he was
determined to keep her far away from
penny and the surface how many times
jerk how many times are we gonna push
each other away until it sticks now
we'll both barchi and bug head on the
rocks it seems that an original
Riverdale ship is sailing back into our
screens horizons that's right the tides
are turning and it seems that Archie and
Betty or barchi as the internet calls
them could be a new contender for
coupledom now what do you think river
babes are you saying bon voyage to bug
head and barchi
start shouting at your ship shaped
thoughts in the comments below as we
dive headfirst and hisses and kisses
okay who else loved all those [ __ ] puns
cuz I really did alright guys
first up in hisses yeah that one go
straight to you Betty Cooper
damn you're damn right it was the dance
what on earth were you thinking girl now
it's bad enough that Archie and Veronica
decided to sing the world's most boring
party song
but did you really think that the best
possible way to save the vibe would be
to strip down in your sexiest lingerie
in front of a crowd of total strangers
middle-aged men and oh yeah
your mother also isn't she like 16
this whole thing was wrong on so many
levels I don't know it's really messed
up now don't get me wrong guys Lilly
Reinhart looked amazing but this whole
scene made me cringe so hard that I
honestly thought that it was another one
of season two's fake-out dreams that
they've been loving so much alright guys
I need to take a second to cool off so
let's take a look at the
behind-the-scenes secrets that Vanessa
Morgan told me about this bizarre
serpent dance I know you were in the
room when they were filming that what
was the vibe like on set oh I felt like
I was watching like a little strip show
you know what I mean it was like um but
like I you know I felt for her too I
think it's just her moment where she's
like showing Chuck and like I will do
anything for you yes
you know I will go extremely out of my
comfort zone I'll get down and like
lingerie and I will do the traditional
female sexist bad dance it's an outdated
sexist surfing tradition try to get it
out loud misogyny dies hard but when you
found out that they had that what was
your reaction when I read this I was
like no way are they having that I was
having a serious panic attack when I was
watching it cuz I'm like your mom is in
the room I was like stranger older guys
or creepy guys probably are like you
know what I mean the poor girl she got
up there didn't lots of times you know
she looked awesome that looks awesome my
one thing was I was like when I was 16 I
don't know where I would have fell in
lingerie that sex yeah I know right
she stole from my mom oh my god mommy's
to be a serpent I bet she has some like
maybe that was the mom's old serpent you
know lingerie outfit she did the dances
oh my gosh well I was actually surprised
when Alice did come over because I was
like why is she not like grabbing her by
the hair cuz my mom would be so upset
and then I realized like she probably
did that in Tibet and then she saw you
know she's doing that for her boyfriends
yeah probably held her back a little bit
mm-hmm
you know before she was like I'm taking
you home all right now let's continue on
with some rapid fire hisses
- Cheryl we're lashing out every time
she feels like Josie's affections are
slipping through her fingers clean that
up please
though I will agree with you girl it was
really creepy that the janitor just
barged into the girls locker room like
that like yeah it's so not okay this is
- the super confusing Reaper and black
hood connection and to the fact that I
had no sense of time in Riverdale
was it really too soon for Archie to say
I love you
I have no idea cuz I had no clue how
long they've actually been dating
regardless hisses - Archie for
immediately throwing his affections and
glances to another girl and my last hiss
is 2fp for giving Jughead an unnecessary
guilt trip your son loves you he was
only trying to help you a veces cut him
some slack
oh when the flipside kisses that one's
going straight to fpn jugheads
motorcycle bonding trip and - the fact
that we were gifted with a rare glimpse
of jugheads hair and it looked beautiful
kisses - more Fred Andrews for Betty
letting down her ponytail and Tony topaz
for being an overall awesome chick sure
why not
now kisses - having so much Alice Cooper
and for watching her embrace her
snake-filled past with a shot or three
of tequila hmm you know it can only be a
matter of time before Betty follows in
her mother's leather least footsteps so
we'll have to see honey one Shirley
Temple oh my gosh you guys that does it
for this week's Sweetwater Secrets
after-show for chapter 21 house of the
devil and next week's episode 209 is the
mid-season finale so there's bound to be
plenty of shockers ahead so get punched
but first hit the comments right now and
tell me what you think of my FP and
Allis hookup Theory how you're feeling
about the bug head barchi and barchi
shakeups and of course your talk kisses
and kisses of the episode now river
babes please give this video a like
share it with your other Riverdale
lovers and subscribe to et's youtube
channel so you never miss an episode of
sweet water secrets see you next time
guys
you